qu'est ce que c'est qu'un jeune
aujourd'hui un jeune homme ou une jeune
femme qui place sa mission et son devoir
au dessus de sa propre usine
[Musique]
quand on est parti en pleine nuit d'une
caserne avec eux pour sauver quelqu'un
d'une overdose d'une tentative de
suicide ou d'un accident de deux-roues
la vie elle est plus là même une fois
qu'on a vu ça
c'est la force du collectif
c'est là la force du groupe qui permet
de comprendre d'appréhender l'indicible
et qui permet au chef dans des
situations qui sont humainement terrible
il est capable de donner un sens au
chaos il est capable de donner un sens à
l'action de ses équipes et c'est tout un
processus qu'on apprend dès que l'on
rentre à l'école et des sapeurs-pompiers
de paris de s'accepter soi même de
connaître ses propres limites mais aussi
d'être capable de travailler en groupe
en collectif l'empathie la discrétion
qui sont des valeurs pour moi qu'il faut
absolument revendiqué dans notre société
qui est une société individualiste
aujourd'hui et ces valeurs vont à
l'encontre de ça c'est un métier de
passion c'est un métier de vocations on
se rend pas compte quand ils viennent
nous sauver la vie parce que on est
souvent dans un état où voilà on ne fait
pas forcément la part des choses et puis
mais c'est des gens très jeunes avec une
extrême maturité alors qu'ils ont
parfois eu 17 18 ans 19 ans et sacré des
personnalités très intéressant je trouve
aujourd'hui dans le cadre de notre
société des gens qui ont sur des
questions essentielles la vie la mort la
fragilité de nos vies à tous une sagesse
une maturité ça c'est assez
impressionnant le métier de banquier
n'est rien sans ce set empreint
d'humanité
cette volonté d'aller vers l'autre et ça
ça s'apprend pas on est câblé pour ça on
ne l'est pas parce qu'on donne quand
même une partie de soi même quand on a
ce type de dialogue avec un monsieur qui
va perdre son épouse ou 1 coupe dans
l'un des deux
conjoint s'est suicidé c'est ce type de
drame on essaie d'apporter une touche
d'humanité mais on y associe parfois
enfin même souvent une partie de ce
fameux pour moi c'est vraiment des
caméléons parce qu'il ya des situations
tellement différente d'une intervention
à une autre ce sont des soldats du feu
mais qui sont quand même confronté à
beaucoup d'autres choses que le feu et
voilà moi quand je suis arrivé à la
brigade effectivement cette empathie qui
pour moi est la clé dans ce que j'ai vu
en tout cas il ya un pompier qui m'a dit
très rapidement si tu n'as pas cette
empathie tu ne deviens pas pompier ou tu
ne restes pas y compris à la 12è
intervention à 2 heures du matin aux
halles à la gare du nord dans des
quartiers difficiles et de manifester la
même empathie vous avez deux personnages
étaient complètement déboussolés
vis-à-vis d'un junkie vis-à-vis d'une
personne
en état d'ivresse et qui sera pas
toujours très très sympathique et c'est
là où c'est le véritable courage